dan carney just got an apartment at like
this uh you know where kids live these
24
and not kids real people live there too
these places where like
you have everything you need by the way
is there
is there anything worse than a human
being
who moves into an apartment complex and
says this they go you got everything you
need they can't everything
you got a whole foods as a teacher well
what do you
need you got everything you need
what the [ __ ] wrong with you i need
much more than that
i need more than a [ __ ] whole foods
and a place to get socks
there's a gym and a pool
and whole foods you have everything you
need what about for your soul
this basic [ __ ] culture of erecting
these
[ __ ] like cheap wood
plastic crap apartment buildings
and then putting them next to a [ __ ]
tj maxx
so you can go in and buy underwear and
they're going you got everything you
need why would you leave
everything's here why would you leave
and meet
people and experience other things
everything that you ever needed is here
in the pod
and then carney talks about it goes my
unit
like he doesn't even say his pizza part
but he goes my
unit he goes the unit doesn't have wash
and draw i'm like
you shut the [ __ ] up the unit
the you i am in the unit and then he
tells me because i'm facing the pool
which is much better than facing the
what are we doing here life should be
about more than this
life should be about more than that i
understand a creature comforts matter
i understand convenience matters i get
it
but using the phrase everything you need
makes you sound like a basic [ __ ]
nobody who just needs so little
that you can live on the side of a
highway and have
socks and [ __ ] peanut butter and
that's
everything you need what are you talking
about
i need culture i need
people to fake their own death i need
people that go to bars
instead of spending time with their
family i need tragedy
i need people reliving traumatic
experiences from their youth
i need people that were in cults that
are
trying to get out of them or getting
into other ones
i need people that have brain injuries
trying to sell me houses
i need things i need more than an
apartment complex which is
[ __ ] 20 30 something staring at each
other
he goes i made a friend there he's a
music manager
my unit endless he's a good kid and i'm
happy he
has an apartment but this whole thing
this whole thing of like let's make life
into this boring [ __ ]
and this hyper consumerist horseshit
where is the old woman who knows the
secrets
of the universe because she was kept in
a cage for the majority of her life
and she realizes that she was because
people loved her
she was angry at them for time but now
she realizes that they
were trying to keep her safe where's
that woman
where are the people who've come out of
jail and realized that jail is the only
fair place left in this country
where are they they're not in your unit
are they at the pool where are the
characters
the people that have the courage to say
that donald trump was too liberal
where are they oh do they provide you a
free continental breakfast
do you get free sure we went and looked
at a at a unit in l.a
steve bings and that was a basic [ __ ]
building too but for rich people
but i only considered living there
because i thought i might get the unit
where steve bing
flung himself out of the window because
i wanted to kill myself
from the same unit and i to because
just the idea of the person the in-house
sales team
having to show the unit again and going
[Music]
i mean we we don't want to even go into
this but steve bing and then also tim
dillon killed himself from this exact
window that's funny to me because then
it's a cursed apartment
and then i have a legacy but these basic
[ __ ] little [ __ ]
you know complexes
he's like you got to come see my spot
man it's pretty cool
oh is it is it pretty cool we can go
walk around whole foods and get bananas
oh is it cool wait me you and the music
manager hang out and get bananas
at the whole foods cause just everything
you need
well i need a little bit more
i need more
than that i'm just saying
everywhere i've lived there's been a uh
a lot of characters and i look at these
new apartment complexes and they're
devoid
of any character anybody that's really
going to say something
cool yeah you know what i mean like
but i'm i'm happy for him and i'm happy
that there are people out there that are
you know he's doing good he's opening
for me has a nice apartment it's good
i just i i have to live in a place where
people have traumatic brain injuries
i have to live in a place where people
invent autoimmune disorders they do not
have
and medicate themselves for them i
that's just my rule
i have to live around glazed eyes
middle-aged women
who claim to have lupus and do not
that is where i must be i must not be
in um the little kearney complex
that's okay